in Blackfoot of familiar face in the
House of Commons not least of all during
prime minister's questions where he's
grilled I think by my maths five
different uh Prime Ministers during his
time as leader of the SNP in Westminster
and in a few days Jane we will have a
new face doing that uh grilling uh
certainly one SMP MP has told me in the
last few minutes that this was a long
time coming certainly I've heard
murmurings for many months that Ian
Blackford may be challenged at the
annual general meeting of the SMP that
of course due next week why well his
party certainly in Westminster does seem
to be pretty divided and the job is very
difficult his colleagues concede one has
described it as herding cats partly
because they are perpetually in
opposition there's no chance of being a
a minister in London of course there is
an opportunity to do that in Edinburgh
if you're on MSP and there are certainly
challenges there has though been
criticism of Mr blackford's handling of
one particular issue that was
the whole ferrago surrounding Patrick
Grady him the former Chief whip of the
party who was accused of sexual
misconduct in eventually suspended for
the House of Commons for two days for a
sexual advance in 2016 at a colleague
the controversy of Mr Blackford is that
he was said to have told colleagues that
they should give Mr Grady quotes his
absolute their absolute full support for
criticized significantly for that
approach certainly some within the party
have welcomed this move including Joanna
cherry and SMP MP and long time critic
of some of the s p leadership she has
said in a tweet I'm pleased to hear this
pleased to hear Mr Blackford is stepping
down it's time for fresh leadership and
tolerance of debate and diverse
viewpoints I hope the SMP Western Group
will now be left to choose our new
leader without outside interference and
in accordance with our standing orders
now who will take over from Ian
Blackford certainly it seems possible
that Stephen Flynn who is a young smpmp
could be one of the favorites he's just
34 years old the shadow business energy
and Industrial strategy spokesperson for
the party seen as a rising star I have
been told some believe he had the
numbers to challenge Ian Blackford and
therefore we'll go ahead and put himself
forward next week that has yet to be
confirmed by Mr Flynn uh or his team it
also I think will raise Jane questions
about Nicholas sturgeon's own leadership
because of course as new Talent comes
forward there is this Perpetual question
over how long Nicholas sturgeon will
stay as SMP leader she's intimately she
wants to stay until at least the next a
general election or even the holyrood
elections but she has been in power for
eight years and that is a behind the
scenes a discussion that is constantly
taking place as for Ian Blackford he's
due to take a different role a less high
profile role engaging with businesses in
the SMP push for Independence he had
said he wanted to be the final SMP uh
Westminster leader and Jane in that
particular aspiration he has failed